on se tourne vers le yémen où la
situation est devenue alarmante selon la
croix rouge en quatorze jours
l'intervention militaire saoudienne
contre les rebelles houthi a fait plus
de 540 morts et 1700 blessés et la
population laissée à elle-même manque de
tout guerre complexe qui amène deux
puissances du monde musulman l'arabie
saoudite sunnite et l'iran chiite à se
disputer le contrôle de la région par
l'entremise de l'insurrection des outils
qui sont chiites l'arabie saoudite de
son côté ne ressent pas encore les
effets de cette guerre mais les frappes
des derniers jours font craindre des
représailles aux frontières par les
insurgés outils notre correspondante
marie ève bédard est allé à la rencontre
des gardes frontière
la frontière entre l'arabie saoudite et
le yémen est depuis longtemps sous haute
surveillance
vous voyez de ce côté-ci la frontière
avec le yémen dit le lieutenant colonel
al ammari voici une de nos tours
d'observation il ya un radar et des
caméras le terrain montagneux du côté
yéménite offre un avantage indéniable à
quiconque chercherait à déjouer la
vigilance des garde-frontières saoudien
some time they use de serment parfois
ils profitent la hauteur des montagnes
pour observer nos patrouilles diriger
leurs opérations comme ça le
lieutenant-colonel
la guerre fait des ravages au delà de
ces montagnes mais ici le principal
souci demeure les trafics en tout genre
avant le début de l'opération le
principal défi c'était le trafic de
drogue d'armes et l'immigration illégale
dit il
il dit s'appeler ghanem et amine 12 10
ans respectivement
ils ont marché pendant deux heures en
terrain hostile pour entrer illégalement
en arabie saoudite
la cargaison qu'il porte sur leur dos
fait facilement l'équivalent de leurs
proies des news de kate ils se servent
souvent des enfants parce qu'on peut
rien faire contre eux on ne peut pas les
arrêter on ne peut que les renvoyer au
yémen dans le cas de cette dame victime
le trafic de drogue dans ce cas-ci du
kpd un psychotrope euphorisant est
passible de la peine de mort par
décapitation en arabie saoudite mais ça
ne suffit pas à décourager la
contrebande
l'arabie saoudite avec tous ces
interdits et un marché lucratif pour la
marchandise illicite en provenance du
yémen et la guerre qui fait rage fait
augmenter la marge de profit en même
temps que les risques et le désespoir
au yémen la population civile est le
prix fort des combats qui font rage et
des bombardements aériens pénurie
d'électricité d'eau et de fournitures
médicales
la population qui voudraient fuir est
coincé par l'intensité de la violence le
comité international de la croix rouge a
pu acheminer cinq tonnes de matériel
pour renflouer ses hôpitaux une goutte
d'eau dans un océan de besoins le cicr
appelle toujours un cessez-le-feu
humanitaire de 24 heures
mais le porte parole de l'armée
saoudienne écarte la possibilité pour le
moment pour le moment nous avons un
campement militaire qui est en cours
nous allons travailler pour réaliser les
objectifs qui ont été déclarés de départ
ici en arabie saoudite on est gardée
bien à l'écart du chaos total et des
combats qui font rage au yémen ce que
l'on voit des opérations militaires
menées par la coalition formée par les
saoudiens se limite à cette salle et ses
modèles réduits ou tous les jours on
présente les faits saillants de la
bataille qui se fait du haut des airs
sur les quelques 300 km dont sont
responsables les hommes du district de
jz and on a redoublé de vigilance depuis
le début de l'opération tempête
décisives plus que les trafiquants ont
craint maintenant des incursions létale
depuis 2006 côté mu ce pourrait être les
milice anti al qaïda ou un autre groupe
dit il
au cours des derniers jours trois de
leurs confrères saoudiens sont tombés
sous les tirs en provenance du yémen la
dernière fois que l'arabie saoudite est
attaquée outils en 2009 la riposte a été
meurtrière ils ont traversé la frontière
et ont occupé un village saoudien un
souvenir douloureux ici est un scénario
qu'on souhaite empêcher de se répéter
ici marie ève bédard radio canada j than
en arabie saoudite